iceland is an isolated country way out
here by itself in the north atlantic
ocean greenland is only 280 kilometers
away but hardly anyone lives there the
faroe islands are 400 kilometers away
but they have a small population as well
the rest of europe is way over there
this isolation is one of the factors
that makes the icelandic language what
it is today a conservative language that
has remained relatively unchanged for
the past 1000 years not unchanged but
relatively unchanged icelandic is the
official language of iceland where the
vast majority of its roughly 330 000
native speakers live that's a very small
number of people not to mention that the
majority of people live in the capital
reykjavik and its surrounding areas and
99 of the people live in cities as a
result there's very little dialectal
variation in icelandic it's pretty much
the same everywhere here's a sample of
what it sounds like yeah yeah that's
[Music]
it's a north germanic language alongside
faroese norwegian danish and swedish
icelandic faroese and norwegian formed
the western branch of north germanic
languages the western branch developed
from the western dialect of old norse
old west norse while the eastern branch
developed from the eastern dialect of
old norse old east norse iceland has its
roots in the arrival of vikings mainly
from western scandinavia who spoke the
western dialect of old norse they began
settling there in the late 9th century
the earliest piece of writing in old
icelandic dates to the early 12th
century and in the 13th and 14th
centuries the icelandic sagas were
recorded documenting iceland's early
history the sagas are thought to have
been memorized and retold for
generations before eventually being
recorded maintaining the older form of
the language old icelandic was old norse
a variety of old west norse it's often
said that icelandic is the closest north
germanic language to old norse at least
in writing the pronunciation has changed
a fair bit icelanders today can still
read the old icelandic sagas with
relative ease but reading them out loud
would sound different from old icelandic
the word relative is important here of
course because icelanders can't read old
icelandic effortlessly i've been told
the experience is like an english
speaker reading shakespeare
iceland came under the control of norway
in the 13th century and ultimately under
denmark when norway entered into a union
with it in 1814 when the denmark norway
union ended denmark kept iceland along
with greenland and the faroe islands
denmark granted the kingdom of iceland
sovereignty in 1918 but it remained in a
union with denmark until 1944 when it
became fully independent
you might assume that there must have
been a lot of danish influence on
icelandic well that was happening in the
19th century but as icelandic
nationalism grew and icelanders began to
seek independence a movement of
linguistic purism began and danish
loanwords were removed from the language
this continues today with words for new
items and concepts being coined from
existing icelandic roots and words
rather than borrowed from other
languages for example the word for phone
is simi which was based on the ancient
word sima which means thread or chord
another example is the word for computer
it was coined from a combination of two
words
meaning number and valve meaning oracle
so the word for computer means something
like number oracle and the word for
video is mint bank a compound word that
means picture band and no bund was not
borrowed from english it existed in old
norse but it did have a parallel or
cognate word in old english
because old norse and old english were
closely related and quite similar
icelandic often feels a little bit like
old english
in old english there were several
letters that we no longer use in modern
english first there's thorn which
represents the voiceless th sound and
then there's f which represents the
voiced the sound both of these letters
are still used in icelandic for those
same sounds then there's the letter ash
which represents an a sound in old
english or sometimes e
it's still used in icelandic though it
represents a diphthong i
in old norse it was pronounced e
there are some sounds in modern
icelandic that you're likely unfamiliar
with there are nasal consonants like
and there are liquid consonants like
but in icelandic these consonants have
voiceless equivalents meaning that
they're said with no resonance in the
vocal cords how can you make a voiceless
you can get an idea of it by whispering
a word that has those sounds
saying a whole word like that is
straightforward but in icelandic the
individual consonant can be unvoiced
even next to vowels here's an example of
a voiceless nasal
this word means champion and at the
beginning of a word a voiceless nasal
can occur represented by the two-letter
combination hn
for example the word meaning knife
i have to be honest i can't really hear
the voiceless quality when it comes at
the beginning of a word can you hear it
here's a word with a voiceless
this means roll or turnover
this typically occurs before a sound and
before a sound
meaning milk
here's a word with a voiceless
this is a noun meaning heart
and can appear at the beginning of a
word represented by hr
meaning complement compare that to the
word for rose rose
another interesting type of sound in
icelandic is ingressive cells sounds
that are made as the speaker breathes in
rather than breathing out as in
norwegian swedish and danish responses
to yes or no questions can be aggressive
but in icelandic full phrases can be
aggressive to show some intensity of
emotion
this means have you heard the news about
sigurdur
yes it's terrible
let's look at some basic phrases in
icelandic so we can examine some more of
the language's features you'll likely
notice a lot of germanic features
including some distant similarities with
english vocabulary
but first a message from our sponsor me
did you know that i have a second
channel on the geofocus channel which i
recently rebooted after a five-year
hiatus i talk about various countries of
the world global issues and so on if you
like educational videos like this one
then check out the geofocus channel the
link is in the description and pinned
comment of this video
and now back to basic phrases in
icelandic
good day this is a very common greeting
golden is the form of the adjective
which is the equivalent of the english
word good
is the equivalent of the english word
day
this phrase is interchangeable with
contain in which
is a definite noun
that greeting is somewhat formal another
greeting commonly used with family and
friends is
when said to a male or science when said
to a female this word actually means
happy and it's a shortened form of this
longer greeting
to a male or what decidal presence to a
female and this means be happy and
blessed
this greeting is also shortened to bless
with the meaning of by as in goodbye
what's your name word for word it's what
are called you
is a cognate of the english word what
meaning they both developed from the
same earlier word
is the second person singular present
tense form of the verb
meaning to be called is the second
person singular nominative personal
pronoun in other words you in the
singular it's a cognate of the archaic
english word thou which was used until
the early modern english period
my name is michael word for word it's i
am called michael here
is the first person singular present
form of the verb
is the first person singular nominative
personal pronoun it's a cognate of the
english pronoun i
these two pronouns ye and thu are
nominative but there are personal
pronouns for each of the four cases
nominative accusative genitive and
dative unlike in english icelandic has
masculine feminine and neuter forms of
they them and their in other words the
third person plural for mixed groups the
neuter is used this sentence is svo
subject verb object but it's more
precise to refer to icelandic as a v2
language the verb is the second element
in the sentence or clause that's the
case for basically all germanic
languages except for modern english
this sentence could also be
michael m called i
but as happens generally in germanic
languages the word order is verb subject
in yes or no questions
is your name michael literally are
called you michael notice that the
subject thu becomes voiced zlu and is
suffixed to the verb in writing
nice to meet you word for word it's
pleasure to become acquainted with you
means pleasure or fun its old english
equivalent was gamin which evolved into
the modern english word game
is the particle used before a verb's
infinitive form so it's translated here
as tu but it's a cognate of the english
word at
kindest may appear to be related to the
english word no but it's actually
distantly related to the english word
can which in old english kunan used to
mean no and its current meaning
developed from the sense of know how to
the active verb is
to make known or introduce
this form with st is used reflexively to
become acquainted with
this is the dative form of the personal
pronoun meaning you in the singular the
dative case is used to show someone is
receiving the action rather than being
the direct object of it
quite a close setting where is the
restroom word for word where is restroom
is a cognate of the english word where
looks like r in english right well
they're related it's a form of the verb
meaning be
but vera looks more like a were than b
doesn't it they're related in english
the infinitive to be and other forms
with b come from a different old english
verb baeon but the past tense and
present tense forms come from old
english weisan a cognate of vesa or wesa
an earlier form of veda
is the definite form of closer the word
for toilet or restroom which is a
loanword from english closet or german
closet despite the tendency to avoid
loanwords it's a neuter noun and if is
the definite article suffix for singular
neutral nouns well at least in the
nominative case like in this sentence
and in the accusative case in the dative
case it's inu and in the genitive case
it's since
that's just for neuter nouns in the
singular there are a lot of different
definite article suffixes so if we
change the noun in the sentence to a
masculine or feminine one the definite
article suffix will be different
where's the police station this noun
meaning police station is feminine and
in is the definite article suffix for
feminine nouns that end in a consonant
in the nominative and accusative case
the word for police station is a
compound noun
meaning police plus stove meaning
station
is the genitive form of
which is also a compound word meaning
law plus
meaning order or rule
is a cognate of the english word law
is actually a borrowing from latin so
again we see that loanwords aren't
entirely absent from icelandic
it's worth mentioning that the word for
police is often shortened to
another sentence
you have a nice watch word for word it's
you singular are with stylish watch this
is one way of expressing the idea of
have an icelandic to be with something
is the second person singular form of
veda the verb meaning to be that we saw
earlier and
is a preposition meaning with
is an adjective meaning stylish or nice
it's the neuter singular accusative form
but there's actually a little more to it
icelandic adjectives have two different
sets of declensions strong which is used
with indefinite nouns and weak which is
used with definite nouns in this case
it's a strong form because the noun
meaning watch has no definite article if
the noun were definite it would look
like this
the nice watch
a definite article suffix and
is the weak declension remember these
greetings that we saw earlier
good day the first one follows this
regular rule goes on is the strong form
of gauzer in the masculine singular
accusative to agree with the noun
because
is indefinite the second one is an
exception to the rule
is the definite form of the noun so
according to the rule the adjective
would be the weak form godza but people
say godan so it's something you just
have to memorize but back to the main
point how do express have in icelandic
there's another way
this also means you have a nice watch
word for word you have stylish watch
is the second person singular present
tense form of the verb
which is actually a distant cognate of
the english word on the old english
equivalent of old norse eja was agan
from which the word on developed
icelandic also has another word for have
have which is a cognate of the english
word but it's not used for possession of
objects only for possession of something
abstract you have
i don't have time word for word i have
not time
f is the first person singular present
tense form of hava hava is also used as
an auxiliary verb
have you ever been to canada word for
word have you some time gone to canada
this sentence uses the present perfect
with hava as the auxiliary verb in the
second person present tense form
and
the supine form of the verb fara which
means go the supine is the same as the
past participle of the verb in its
neuter singular form
like english icelandic really has two
standalone tenses present and past but
has numerous compound tenses with
auxiliary verbs like this that combine
tense and aspect the icelandic word hava
comes from old norse hava and the
english word have comes from old english
habban or havian it's interesting to
look at just how much the english verb
has become simplified and lost many of
its conjugated forms in the present
tense there's just have and has and in
the past tense there's just had
but if we look at modern icelandic
versus old norse we can see that it
retains very similar conjugations
from all the examples and breakdowns in
this video it's probably clear that
icelandic retains a lot of the
inflection that has been lost in other
germanic languages and because it's
remained relatively close to old norse
icelandic feels a little like you've
entered a time warp and are listening to
old norse or even old english from a
thousand years ago if you're a native
speaker of icelandic are you able to
understand the old icelandic used in
writings like the icelandic sagas
and to other people what's your
impression of icelandic and its features
once again it's time to say thanks to
all of the langfocus patreon supporters
especially the ones whose names appear
on the screen they are the top tier
patreon supporters so many extra special
thanks go out to them if you're
interested in the north germanic
languages check out my video on
norwegian i guarantee you'll learn
something new about it that you didn't
know before